ok entro la fine di questa chiamata lo
decideremo cosa fare come danno ps film
di mare di jamal un emozione poter fare
si trova sempre
certo con una bambina in corso tutte
limitazioni del caso pensate se così
facendo ma poco sarà fare un ultimo
minuto
non funziona così amo ma io conosco
tutti proprietari di tutte le discoteche
non c'è problema il problema è che non
ci sarà nessun riscontro aperto visto
che non mi sembrate molto informate che
la faccio breve o cenone ristorante con
festa in casa e non ha riso latte ci
sarà sì 6 70 anni ha comunque dire anche
luca forse ti sei confusa perché avevamo
detto no ragazzi per capodanno festa in
casa contro mila persona prende il
compito anche no ok io lo vedevo in
campagna le tue in accenderci camino
guardarci faccio perché non c'è neanche
a tv ma in tutto ciò esaminato prima
decidiamo dove andare poi cosa mettere
come un viaggio madrid barcellona con
quali soldi raga aiutatevi 58 va bene ho
capito